this week on The Last of Us
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay here we go
virtual change thank you
yes I finally found a worse Halloween
costume than the time my pregnant
girlfriend thought this was an
acceptable fit episode 7 of The Last of
Us has all the booze drinking Maul fun
that takes me back to my teenage years
and in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the episode answering
questions like how Joel might have
inadvertently killed this guy and a lot
more fun details from the game warning
there will be some minor spoilers from
the game but nothing too major but
before we get into it make sure to like
And subscribe seriously less than 20 of
you are subscribed because Here We Go
episode 7 is titled Left Behind or
basically every vacation my parents went
on without me last episode we saw Joel
take a home run to the chest when a
literal baseball bat cracked into his
gut a slight deviation from the game
where he falls off his second story
ledge right onto a steel rod that's got
to hurt I don't care where you're from
fun fact the horse at the end of episode
six lovingly named kallus has sparked a
lot of controversy whether or not it's
actually real lock in your answers now
because at the end of the video I'll
reveal the answer a trail of blood
through the Colorado suburbs leads us to
a distraught Ellie hovering over the
body of Joel this situation is extremely
dire with Joel telling Ellie to take the
gun and make her way back to Tommy a
decision that would inevitably leave
Joel to die but part of this episode's
theme deals with choice and how we deal
with those on the brink of death Ellie's
Journey with Riley parallels her journey
with Joel both Riley and Joel are
protector characters in fact in the
American Dreams comic it's Riley who
beats up a kid bullying Ellie in episode
5 Ellie told us her greatest fear was
ending up alone and later in episode 6
that everyone who's gotten close to her
is either died or left her Ellie could
have left Joel there to die but instead
embarks on a search for medical supplies
that departs drastically from the game
the title Left Behind is a nod to The
Last of Us Us Part 1's DLC think of it
as a mini expansion to the main game it
starts off pretty similar to the show
with an injured Joel in desperate need
of Aid however the game takes Ellie
through the infected Colorado Mountain
plaza where she must make her way to a
downed military copter in the search of
its first aid kit not to mention fight
off some murderous group of cannibals if
the previews are correct we'll be seeing
these cannibals and their leader David
in the next episode or two this whole
cannibal section at the mall was likely
cut from the show due to a mixture of
budget time constraints and the fact we
already have this huge Mall segment
between Riley and Ellie most of the
episode is a flashback to Ellie's time
at a federal-run military prep school
where kids are trained to become fedra
soldiers in the game we actually see one
of these schools in Pittsburgh I see
back in the box back in episode one we
learned from leader of the fireflies
Marlene that she put Ellie into a
federal orphanage shortly after her
mother Anna's death Marlene and Anna
were good friends but a lot of their
past remains unknown Riley says of
Marlene's relationship with Anna
apparently they like argued and fought a
lot but they were close we even get to
see a wanted Marlene poster on their
journey in the game upon turning 13
ephedra orphans are transferred to one
of these prep schools which is where the
American Dreams Comics begin the events
of the comics take place before the Left
Behind DLC and Chronicle how Ellie met
Riley and their budding friendship the
show however drops us right into the
action with Ellie listening to her
Walkman at the military academy the
Walkman is a recurring item throughout
the comic with Riley even stealing it
just like she does in the show I was
definitely
probably gonna give it back the song
that plays is Pearl Jam's all or none a
bidding choice for this episode
considering its emphasis on hopelessness
and the feeling of being alone school
bully Bethany is quick to taunt the
defenseless Ellie now that her protector
Riley has seemingly vanished you don't
fight your friend fights
she's not here anymore this plays out a
little differently in the comic with
Ellie's arrival at the Academy
accompanied with a punch the head by a
male bully however this time it's Riley
who saves her in the show Ellie defends
herself sending Bethany to the infirmary
with 15 stitches but not without getting
a pretty bad Shiner herself Captain
Quang here sort of the principal of the
school knows Ellie has potential but she
squanders it stating that she's so smart
but also so stupid and he basically
outlines two pounds in life for her she
could graduate to become a grunt being
told what to do living a [__] life and
likely to die by a firefly or choose
path 2. become an officer where she'll
get her own room and be able to tell the
bethanies of the world just where to
shove it the officer keys he shows her
are emblazoned with the naughty dog paw
print logo the studio that made The Last
of Us games one day Ellie could have a
set of her own if she'd simply follow
the rules in the captain's mind fedra
are the good guys we're the only thing
holding this all together which is a
great way to set up Riley's care
character who stands up against fedra
and what she believes to be an
authoritarian Rule now Ellie's room is
chock full of little Easter eggs we have
dinosaurs on the wall which Ellie loves
is it a dinosaur
maybe I'll be your friend again if it's
a dinosaur she even has a book on
paleontology there's the lunar phases
poster which can also be found in the
game this baseball may even allude to
the bat Riley will later use to fight
off the infected or it might just be a
nod to the baseball bat weapon from the
game there's also a tape featuring Etta
James who sung I Got You Babe based off
the 1965 sunny and Cher song actually
plays in both the game and show during
the dance scene the same is true with
the hits of aha whose song Take On Me
plays in the episode and was also the
background music for the official
trailer no way and we can't forget will
Livingston's no pun intended volume 1
and not to be confused with volume 2
which is gifted to Ellie by Riley and
later seen in episode 4. there's a
Savage Starlight comic one of which we
saw in episode 5 and these make
appearances all throughout the games as
Collectibles fun fact Ellie tells Sam
she owns volumes 4 5 6 and 11 but the
copy we see her in her room is volume 8.
in the game this copy can be found while
escaping David's men 10 at the Lakeside
Resort there are also tons of posters
involving space from galaxies to even a
movie poster for Red Planet a sci-fi
horror starring Val Kilmer from the year
2000. another movie poster is the 1987
film Inner Space starring Dennis Quaid
and Martin Short in which a scientist is
injected into Martin Short and is able
to control his body sounds a bit like
how the cordyceps operate we can also
see Ellie's switchblade an item that has
sentimental value for her since it was a
gift from her mother nothing says love
like a switchblade there's a Mortal
Kombat 2 poster which foreshadows her
eventually playing it near the end of
the episode and how she also came across
one at the gas station in episode 3.
just like in the game Ellie Slumber is
interrupted by Raleigh but there are a
few key differences that are important
to point out the show is a lot more
ambiguous as to what Ellie and Riley are
compared to the game are they friends or
something more Ellie's far more
apprehensive making a move on Riley and
even asks Riley to turn away when she
gets changed so later asked Riley if she
met some Firefly dude that brainwashed
her into becoming a firefly the game on
the other hand heavily implies the two
were romantic before Riley's
disappearance we were good
we were better than good and then you
told me to [__] off and then you just up
and vanish Riley had left to join the
fireflies and in the game we learned
she's been gone for 46 days leaving
Ellie to believe she's dead Riley proves
to Ellie she's part of the Fireflies by
brandishing her gun however in the game
she shows her Firefly dog tag Riley and
Ellie had talked about liberating the qz
but that doesn't necessarily mean you
have to join the fireflies Ellie
believes them to be a terrorist
organization what a terrorist dumped me
with Federal Riley tells Ellie that
she'll reveal everything to her but she
has to come with her to experience the
quote-unquote best night of her life
it'll definitely be a night that changes
her life forever bonus points if you
caught the giraffe on the wall here if
you've been watching any of my videos
for the past couple of weeks you'll know
giraffes are one of the shows and game's
biggest Easter eggs which foreshadow an
upcoming iconic scene on their way out
the two were nearly caught by a federal
Patrol and Ellie makes note that it
could have easily turned into a
situation that left her with that scar
above her eye this is really interesting
because up until now the mystery behind
that scar has been unknown in an
interview with Eurogamer Ashley Johnson
and Neil druckman had this to say about
the scar I think he he just likes
eyebrow scarves
there is a story but we're not we're not
rebellious so this scene gives us a
little tidbit that her scar happened
during a quote 7-Eleven incident whether
that's a nod to the chain of convenience
stores or a specific date remains to be
seen my guess is scalding hot dog
accident makes me want a hot dog real
bad it's here that Riley says one of the
most important lines in the episode you
can't fight everything and everyone you
can pick and choose what's important
Ellie will later Heed These words when
she chooses to stay with Joel instead of
go off on her own the building they
break into are the Liberty Apartments
Liberty is a big theme in Boston not
only due to its roots in American
independence But the irony that the city
itself is now under authoritarian
control the mall is named Liberty
Gardens and the name of the museum is
the freedom Museum of Boston the two
make their way up to the seventh floor
and find a dead body one which Riley
says wasn't there before he has a bottle
of Hamlin whiskey which is hilarious
considering Stuart Hamblin of which it's
named after was a well-known supporter
of the temperance movement but more
interesting are these pills which look
suspiciously like the same pills Joel
gave to the fedra soldier in episode 1.
it's totally possible Joel has been
dealing these for quite some time and
that they've found their way to the
everyday citizens of the qz and this
poor guy just decided to off himself in
a derelict building on the rooftop Ellie
takes a swig of booze and pretends to
like it it's great but we know when she
has some of Joel's in episode six it's
not our cup of tea
in the game Ellie and Riley steal some
Hooch from Winston a U.S army patrol
officer stationed at the mall who taught
Ellie how to ride a horse his name is
even mentioned in the game Winston this
Soldier back in the zone he gave me
lessons we also see yet another example
of Ellie's fascination with guns asking
Riley if she can hold hers throughout
the season we've seen Ellie asked to be
trained in the opening of episode 4 has
her in a full-on Love Fest with one a
gun is a physical manifestation of the
protective quality she looks for in
others a gun is power in a world that is
ruthless and violent according to Riley
it was Marlene who converted her to the
fireflies unlike Ellie Raleigh remembers
that feeling of having a family of
having a home she misses that and hopes
the fireflies will give her that feeling
again in the show she didn't have to go
through any initiations she said yes and
voila she became a firefly but the DLC
she had to undergo some trials you've
run into more infected
as part of my initiation they actually
made me kill this just like in the game
the two Venture above the rooftops and
to me it kind of looked like it was
inspired by the beginning of the Matrix
from the sunlights to shots of
characters jumping from roof to roof now
the show does a better job at explaining
how this giant abandoned mall is able to
be powered stating that these apartments
next to it recently expanded to allow
for more citizens had the inadvertent
fact of also supplying power to the mall
something Riley found out when she was
stationed there to keep tabs on a hidden
stash of pipe bombs but we'll get to
that in a bit supposedly this mall was
sealed off long ago because of the
infected but Riley says it's safe and
that she knows a way in and even the
dialogue here foreshadows the terror to
come are you gonna kill me this seems
like a perfect place to do it Ellie is
treated to an amazing view as the mall
lights turn on she's probably never seen
a mall in her life at least not like
this and I like how there's a video game
store turbo gaming on the top right here
and a GameStop later on this entire
sequence was shot at a a real mall
called Northland Village in Calgary
Alberta fortunately because the mall's
been boarded up the lights and noise
shouldn't disturb any of those pestering
fedra patrols as Riley will later refer
to this place as a huge bunker what
awaits are the four wonders well
technically five since Ellie refers to
the escalator as the fifth these are
four major attractions Riley's prepared
to show Ellie but before we get there
there's a secret I want to show you no
not Victoria's Secret the dawn of the
wolf 2 poster a movie that can be found
in the games now if you look really
closely you can make up the tagline
everyone wants to be found for the
second film playing here at this theater
which I'll reveal the title to at the
end of the video hint it's a 2003 best
picture nominee the mole itself has been
looted of all the good stuff and this
Footlocker looks as though it's just
survived a Black Friday sale the first
of the four wonders is the carousel a
scene taken directly from the game we
get a beat of romantic tension between
the two before the carousel breaks down
and Ellie questions Riley if she really
believes they could one day liberate
this place according to Riley the
fireflies have liberated other qzs this
shouldn't be confused with the
liberation of Kansas City which we saw
in episodes four and five remember that
was not done by the fireflies and at
this point the timeline hasn't even
occurred yet it's here that Riley
divulges what her future would have been
like should she have stayed in Boston
remember how Captain Kwong said you
either graduate a grunt or officer well
Riley got assigned a grunt position
literally she got sewage detail she
doesn't want to spend the rest of her
life standing guard while people shovel
[__] so she panicked and ran away
finding the longer she was away from
Ellie the harder it was for her to come
back you know you're the one thing I
miss from that [__] place the second
wonder is the photo booth a moment taken
directly from the game with details the
same right down to their very poses in
the game you can actually choose from
three different themes love friends and
cool they pull off bunny ears perhaps a
nod to the bunny from the game a scary
one and back to back unfortunately in
the game same version they never get a
printed copy of their photos
100 up here the third wonder is raja's
arcade which looks pretty damn similar
to The Game's version down to its purple
Neon Lights remember that purple in the
last of us has been a dominant color
throughout the season represented
through characters like Sarah Ellie Tess
and Florence now the game didn't get the
permission like the show to display
classic arcade games such as Tetris
Frogger and Daytona USA so they had to
change them to more fun names like
instead of Bubble Bobble we have gobbley
boy but the fiesta resistance is Mortal
Kombat 2. in episode 3 Ellie came across
a broken version of the game and
recounted when a friend of hers played
as Molina whose character's fatality
turned others to Bones Ellie has been
close-lipped about Riley not wanting to
discuss it further with Marlene and when
Tess asked her in episode 2 if she had
some sort of boyfriend coming after her
she shrugs it off because well she's
into women in the game Mortal Kombat 2
is replaced with a fictitious Title by
the name of the turning and Molina
replaced with a character named Angel
knives unfortunately the game's version
doesn't work instead Riley makes Ellie
close her eyes and pretend to play by
describing how it works meanwhile in
this creepy doll shop and infected
Springs to life this shot was taken
right from the game in a shop called
American princess dolls Riley and Ellie
almost kissed because that's what you do
after a successful fatality with Baraka
prompting Ellie to get a little freaked
out and say she has to go home but
there's still something Riley wants to
show her as they pass a dilapidated food
court one that has a Thai Express which
is a Canadian company that didn't exist
in 2003 when the pandemic came out
Raleigh shows Ellie her living quarters
at amacho nacho an actual food court
restaurant found in the game there she
surprises Ellie with no pun intended
Volume 2 and a pun that appears in both
the show and game what did the triangle
say to the circle what did the triangle
say to the circle you're so pointless
but Ellie has had enough when she
stumbles upon a stash of pipe bombs as
stash Riley was ordered to protect as
part of the fireflies how can Ellie be
friends with someone who might be
ordered to kill her then Riley drops
this bomb that it's her last night in
Boston before she's shipped off to
Atlanta and she wanted to give Ellie a
special goodbye all we really know about
the Atlantic qz comes from episode one
there's a factory there that makes only
two things bullets and painkillers now
Riley asked Marlene if Ellie could come
but Marlene said no this is likely
because she promised Ellie's mother to
keep her safe and as she said in episode
1 the safest place for her is to be with
Vedra Ellie leaves the whole night has
been a flood of emotion but she
ultimately makes the choice to come back
just like she makes the choice to come
back to Joel in the game it's actually
Riley who gets upset and leaves and
Ellie chases her so this was an
interesting change with Ellie on her way
back to Riley as scream leads her to the
fourth Wonder Party City inspired
Halloween store plucked right from the
game game even down to the very Mass
they wear I wonder if that's a dawn of
the wolf mask in the game the Halloween
store segment actually comes before
raja's arcade the photo booth and
Carousel Unfortunately they had to cut
skeleteer am I ever getting boobs or
what another segment from the game that
was cut is where Ellie and Riley take
turns throwing bricks at Cars Plus some
of these off-color puns the [__]
psychic escaped prison
he was a small medium at large now if
you play through all the different puns
the game has to offer I think there are
around a dozen of them you'll notice a
familiar one from the end of episode 4.
diarrhea is hereditary you're once in
your jeans you're a weird kid and I'm
sure a lot of you are sad to see the
water gun fight cut from the show this
was more of a game mechanic more than
anything and would probably be silly if
they kept it in the show so I understand
why it was cut Ellie lays out all of her
feelings what is she supposed to think
when her best friend abandoned her came
back made her this amazing night only
for her to leave again to fight for her
cause she doesn't even think Riley
understands herself and maybe Ellie May
Never Fully comprehend Riley's decision
that in the fireflies she found family
that thing she desires most Ellie asks
if she's sure she wants to join and
Riley nods she's going to miss her best
friend but understands it's her choice
when all seems to be mended between the
two Riley brings her up to dance which
is just a step better than my own as the
song quiets Down Ellie tells Riley not
to go and Riley agrees Ellie goes in for
the kiss
I'm sorry
well the two laugh uncertain of what's
to come they're a brief moment of
happiness is interrupted by infected in
the game it's multiple Runners which
chase them through the back quarters of
the mall while the show version stays
contained to the store with one the
outcome however in both versions is the
same Ellie and Riley are both bit Riley
on the hand and Ellie on the arm now the
show chooses to flash back to Ellie in
Colorado searching for supplies which
could help Joel the game has her
returning to him with a first aid kit
having to fend off the cannibal
attackers from getting to Joel locked in
the yogurt shop in both versions Ellie
takes out a rage while Riley has already
given into the reality of the situation
they have two options the easy way AKA
shoot themselves or to be quote
unfortunately for Riley there is no
option three in both versions we never
see what happens to Riley and Ellie at
this point doesn't know that she's
immune we do know that Riley eventually
succumbs to her infection but just what
exactly happened is not known in episode
4 Ellie tells Joel that the man she shot
to save him wasn't the first person she
shot could the first be Riley who she
stayed with until she turned all we know
is that sometime between Riley's death
in episode 1 Marlene picked up Ellie and
kept her locked for several weeks to
determine if she was immune from the
infection both versions have Ellie
stitching up Joel with an extra shot in
the game showing Joel tied to a rig on
the back of their horse according to the
game Ellie had practice with stitching
her own arm as we near the end of the
video I have answers for those waiting
about the horse and movie poster yes
that horse is indeed real according to
the editor of the episode Timothy good
they needed the horse to be extremely
still so as to not take the eyes off
Joel and Ellie in this pivotal scene in
that movie post from the mall that
belongs to 2003's best pitcher nominee
Lost in Translation thanks for watching
everyone please be sure to like And
subscribe and let me know your thoughts
and theories about the show below or
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember
[Music]